[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 154 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my wonderful colleague
Melanie Warrick.
[LAUGHTER]
Hello, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
I forgot her name.
Hi Mark, how are you?
MARK MANDEL: I didn't expect
the [INAUDIBLE] response.
I'm good, how are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good too.
All right, well Mark, this
week we have G Suite--
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--on our docket.
We have Alicia and Joanna
joining us this week,
which is really great.
And before we get into
that, as always, we
will start off with our
cool things of the week
and we will end with our
question of the week.
And this question
comes all the way
from Mark, which is, what
if I want to write a code
sample with a link that
opens the Cloud Console
and automatically clones a Git
repository into Cloud Shell?
MARK MANDEL: That was
a lot of alliteration.
I just realized that.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Not a problem at all there.
MARK MANDEL: No.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyway,
so let's go ahead
and start out with our
cool things of the week.
And I want to start out
by giving a shout out
to Sara Robinson, one
of our colleagues,
who posted up a
great post last week.
And she specifically talks about
classifying congressional bills
with machine learning.
You know, she's always
looking for good data sets
and she found this
open source dataset
with 400,000
congressional bills.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
MELANIE WARRICK: And it
had like 20 plus data
points for each bill.
So she worked with that
on doing classifications.
And some of the data
points she lists,
she also lists her process
for training an AutoML Natural
Language model, so she
used that as her tool.
And she talked about
how she evaluated it,
got predictions
from it, and how you
can use it and find the
stuff that she put together
and play around with it.
Yeah, so she gives you
all the great information
you need and you can look
this up and play around
with the code later
if you'd like.
So check it out.
MARK MANDEL: So we
actually mentioned this
during the podcast, but
it's the third installment
of the "Serverless From
the Ground Up" series
by Martin Omander, talking
about how to integrate
Google Cloud with G Suite.
And this time, they actually
are integrating Cloud Firestore
into the mix with some
Cloud Functions and Pub/Sub,
with the spreadsheet and
all the other good things,
to kind of expand
on the set of things
that they were
building previously
to manage this document system.
So well worth read, and we also
talk about it in the interview
as well.
So it's definitely a cool thing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Another cool thing
of the week is,
we're going to include a
link to this blog post on how
20th Century Fox is
using machine learning
to predict a movie audience.
So this is very
applicable for anybody
who's actually trying to
understand their core audience.
And they specifically
talk about the details
on how they built out
their data pipeline
and established this
model that helps
them understand and predict
what audiences will come out.
And they explained how they did
their validation of this model
as well, and just how valuable
it's been for their data teams
and their marketing
teams to have greater
insight into the audience.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Look into that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Also relevant for today, there's
a new and improved G Suite
developer hub.
So if you're looking to build
integrations with G Suite,
either with other
G Suite products,
or with Cloud, or all
sorts of other fun stuff,
there is a new hub that
you can get access to,
which allows you to
get started quickly.
You can view and
manage your triggers,
you can view and manage
your App Maker app,
see executions in real time.
Also, it's real pretty.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then
we want to give a shout out
for last week's Google Doodle,
which included this really
adorable game with ghosts.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
It was the--
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark was
so excited about this.
MARK MANDEL: It was the very
first multiplayer Google
Doodle.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Which
was super cool,
and it ran on top of
Google Cloud Platform.
I think it ran
really, really well
and also integrated a
good friend of mine,
Joseph Holly's open source
project called Open Match--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, well--
MARK MANDEL: --for
doing matchmaking.
MELANIE WARRICK: If you still
want to play around with that,
we've got the link and
you can check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Before we run away
to our interview,
congratulations to Melanie.
She has put up with me for
a whole year at this point.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Lots of therapy.
MARK MANDEL: And
she hasn't left yet.
So--
MELANIE WARRICK: Lots
and lots of therapy.
MARK MANDEL: --thank you.
Thank you very much
for not leaving.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's been fun.
It's been a good year.
We've done a lot in this year.
MARK MANDEL: We've done a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
we will talk more
about that at the
end of the year too.
MARK MANDEL: We will.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
So Mark, I think it's
time for us to go talk
with Alicia and with Joanna.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Well, I'm very excited today
to have two delightful people
joining us.
We have Joanna Smith,
developer advocate for G Suite,
as well as Alicia
Williams, teammate of ours
in Cloud Advocate as well.
How are you both doing?
JOANNA SMITH: Good.
I can't speak for
Alicia, but I'm great.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Doing great today.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much for coming
and hanging out with us today.
We're going to talk to you
all about G Suite and all
the things involved in that.
Before we do that, do
you want to tell us
a little bit about who you
are and what you're doing?
Alicia, you're sitting next
to me, why don't you go ahead?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Well, I'm an advocate really
focused on data analysis,
discovering how they can use
both G Suite and GCP together
to solve their problems.
MARK MANDEL: And Joanna?
JOANNA SMITH: So
I'm the one who gets
to be responsible for all of the
online content for both G Suite
developers and also
the Power Users, which
is kind of like a new
thing we're doing.
It's just, Alicia
and I are trying
to make sure that anybody can
build a custom or productive
solution to make their
day better and not
have to do that
annoying thing you have
to do every Tuesday that
ruins your day for like three
hours in a spreadsheet.
MARK MANDEL: What is
the annoying thing that
happens every Tuesday?
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe for you it's like,
making all the links so
that all the people
who are remote
like me, and can't be in San
Francisco to make a podcast,
and you keep
forgetting to make them
links, and wouldn't it be
great if you could just
have your spreadsheet of
your calendar and be like,
create link for
remote podcasting
and it would do it for you?
MELANIE WARRICK: Helping
automate and simplify things
for people.
JOANNA SMITH: Simplify your day
so you can get your job done.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well
if there's anyone out
there who doesn't
know, what is G Suite?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Well, G Suite--
do you use Gmail, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Maybe.
[LAUGHTER]
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Maybe.
MARK MANDEL: I use Inbox.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Maybe that's--
MARK MANDEL: I use Inbox.
I just want to be
clear about that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Maybe that's all
I use because Inbox
might be going somewhere?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: We might
be using it right now.
No, so--
[LAUGHTER]
--those apps actually--
MELANIE WARRICK: So true.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: --that
collection of apps
is called G Suite.
So thinking Gmail, also
Sheet Stocks, Calendar.
JOANNA SMITH: But it's
not just like the docs.
The real thing that we
like to stress to everybody
is that G Suite
is collaborative.
So your whole suite of office
and productivity applications
are meant to be easy to use,
but also easy for us to use.
So you don't have to download
a file, attach it to an email,
send it over to somebody
so they can download it,
and then open it, and then edit
it, and send it back to you
and you hope that you
understand what's going on.
We're trying to make working
easier through collaboration.
And that's why it's so
much fun for people like me
all by myself in a remote
office not getting to hang out
in the podcasting room.
[LAUGHTER]
But also--
MELANIE WARRICK:
I feel like we're
going to be talking
about being remote--
MARK MANDEL: A lot, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: --a lot
throughout this, yes.
JOANNA SMITH: I'm from Texas
and I like people and I know it.
I'm very proud of my home.
Really, it's
collaboration, G Suite.
And then the other thing that
is my favorite about G Suite
is how extensible it is.
They designed this product to
be customizable so that anybody
could build anything with it.
Partly because we designed
it for ourselves first
and then we started selling
it because people liked it,
but also because it's
nice to be able to take
something and tweak it,
and add something to it
so that you can get your
day to be a better day.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
And so really, I mean, we're
talking about all the products
that really fall into
Google Drive, what you're
able to do, the Gmail
and all these things,
which people don't
probably think about
all that much anymore
because they're using them
and they're just sort
of part of your life.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah,
it's just expected.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: You
don't think about it.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
it has to actually
be supported, and
built, and established.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: And
it does a lot more
than you think it does.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What does it do?
MARK MANDEL: What else
does it do that you don't
know it does and think it does?
[LAUGHTER]
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I think that's
what today's podcast is about.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
think that is, yes.
Well, OK.
What are some of the favorite
things you have about G Suite?
What are some of the
favorite products
or favorite functionality?
Why do you like G Suite?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Well,
I think everybody knows
my favorite product is Sheets.
So I worked many years
as a program manager,
and I kind of got
to the point where
I could do anything in a Google
Sheet, much to the dismay--
MARK MANDEL: Anything?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: --of my team.
Anything, Mark.
I could track anything,
mail merge, send emails
when things are overdue,
a lot of different things
you can do from a Sheet even
though it's not necessarily
built to be--
I think Sheets is one
of those products that
was built to do one thing and
now it does thousands of things
because it is so flexible.
So that's my favorite product.
JOANNA SMITH: I've got to say,
I'm voting for Gmail here.
Not even Inbox, just old
school classic Gmail.
Because one, I don't
know if you remember,
but way back when we all signed
up for Gmail a long time ago,
it was the first email
that was ever threaded.
So your reply to an email
showed up next to the email
that you originally got.
And I remember that
changing the way
that I viewed speaking to
people on the internet, I guess.
But the other thing is
that Gmail has grown,
and it's this powerhouse
of great features
to help you keep
your life in order.
And the way that I
can prove that is,
we all can't deny that
Google runs on email.
Everything from our bug systems,
our CLs, our code submissions,
is the build broken, this is
all handled through email.
And that's why we had
to create our own email
service, because no
others could keep up.
And that's why it's been
such a successful email
provider for so many people.
And also for so many companies.
So it's my favorite because
it's an oldie but goodie.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
So Alicia, you were talking
about how you could do anything
in Sheets.
How did you do
anything in Sheets?
Like, you were talking about
sending emails from Sheets.
Like how-- there's no
spreadsheet function
for sending email
in a cell, is there?
Or, how does that work?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Well, that's
more of a recent addition
to the types of
things that I can do,
but that's through Apps Script.
So Apps Script is a JavaScript
based language, I've
been learning.
So I spent many years
just using the UI,
doing everything you can
do in Sheets, and Docs,
and Gmail with the UI.
And then I started
discovering that behind
a lot of the spreadsheets
and docs at work
were these scripts that
other people had written.
I started dabbling in those,
editing them when I needed to,
and then finally
decided it was time
to learn to write my own to
do things that no one else had
written to do.
Yeah, it's something that you
can write standalone scripts
that call multiple docs
and spreadsheets together
to get something
done, or you can have
just behind one spreadsheet.
You can use Apps
Script to automate
many of the things that
happen in your spreadsheet
or to call out to other
services to bring those
into your spreadsheet as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is
there a public spot
for people to share Apps
Scripts that they like to write?
JOANNA SMITH: So not as
much that you like to write.
We have a pretty active
community across G+,
also across Stack
Overflow and GitHub.
But there's also a marketplace
where a lot of companies
will create applications that
they sell to other companies
to make days better.
And then you can also put
them up for free as well.
Like one of my favorite
isn't actually available.
To be clear about
this, it was just
written by someone on our team
and then shared internally,
but you can make it
yourself as well.
Is, we have a calendar, and
it's a team vacation calendar.
And the way we manage
it is not by everyone
putting their vacation
on a second calendar that
is hard to remember
and you don't really
want to think about, but
we have an Apps Script that
runs every night at midnight
and looks at everyone's calendar
and then copies any
event called out
of office or vacation to
the team vacation calendar
programmatically and easily.
MARK MANDEL: How do I add
those, are those the add-ons,
is that a thing?
JOANNA SMITH: It's
actually different.
It's not different
but it is different,
and you're just going to
have to trust me on this
as I explain it.
So anybody can add an Apps
Script anywhere pretty much.
They're great for
mainly the editors,
so Docs, Sheets, Slides, Forms,
but also in Drive themselves.
And all Apps Script are ran
from Drive, saved in Drive.
And the editor you can access
by going to Script.google.com.
But you can also create a script
inside of a specific sheet
by clicking on Tools and
Script Editor in there.
And that script will then
be bound to that sheet.
So when you share
the sheet, the script
goes with it to
other people as well.
That has its own advantages
versus standalone App Scripts.
And then add-ons are
created with Apps Script.
They're powered by Apps
Script, but then add-ons
can span over to
Gmail, to Calendar.
They're a little more robust.
And then one of the great
things about add-ons
is, you write it
all up once and then
Google does the hard work of
making it work for Gmail on web
and Gmail on mobile.
MARK MANDEL: So the--
you were talking about learning
JavaScript and Apps Script
and playing with this
stuff a lot more.
How have you found
the editor experience?
Because as Joanna touched
on that a little bit,
how is that integrated IDE
type thing, how does that work?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: So
for me it's basically
the difference between even
starting to look at it.
I didn't want to have to install
any packages on my computer,
or decide on an IDE.
I didn't even know what
that stood for at the time.
[LAUGHTER]
So having the editor
in the browser
is really what made it
so accessible to me.
And you talked a
little bit about how
to find where people
share these things.
And we do have a lot of
samples in our documentation
and on GitHub.
But you'll find that people
share them all over the place.
And just by using
Search, I tend to find--
I like to start
out with something.
So if I have nothing
to start out from,
I'll just take a random
script and put it in there
and then just
start editing away,
because I think it's really
helpful to have a place
to start.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
So there is a lot
out there that you can get--
maybe it's only 5%
of the way there,
but it gives you
a place to start.
And I find those actually
on Stack Overflow
as well, there's Apps
Script community there.
And then we have a lot of
actually Google Developer
experts that blog about it,
and it's really helped me.
I had to for a demo create a
way to automatically submit
to a Google form as part of the
demo, which is not something
you would typically do.
Typically you would
submit to the form.
But I wanted to submit
a lot of form responses
all at once in front
of an audience.
And I was actually able by using
Search to find somebody that
had done something similar.
And it was an area where just
going to our documentation,
because it wasn't a common use
case, I was getting nowhere.
So I was pretty excited
and surprised to find it,
and I was able to then
build that functionality
into my demo.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
You and I are
definitely the same
in terms of working
with a blank page,
just grabbing
something, something
to start out with, I definitely
respect and understand that.
I know there are APIs.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the APIs?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Oh, the API.
The APIs are actually
something I haven't really
delved into yet, but
I think Joanna has.
JOANNA SMITH: I can
touch on this briefly.
Basically, we have so many
APIs for so many services.
And as you would expect,
we've got an API for Sheets.
So that can basically
provide all the functionality
that Apps Script
provides as well.
And these are all REST
APIs and we offer them
through client libraries
in so many languages,
trying to make sure we can
support any kind of use case
you have as a developer.
But the other cool
thing about the APIs
is, we have a lot that are
specifically really meant
to be used by a
domain administrator,
or somebody who's trying
to manage their company
and uses G Suite, the
enterprise side of it.
You know, let's say
you're hiring people,
so you can put them in and out
of your system with the people
in the Contacts API.
There's an Admin
SDK that actually
lets you do all kinds of
controls for your organization,
but programmatically.
So you don't have to do
everything by going into Chrome
and clicking, and then
adding, and then typing.
It's like, wouldn't it
be great if you just
had a list somewhere and
it all uploaded for you?
And so, those are
really, really cool.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
like a really great chance
to discuss the
differences between G
Suite as the free
consumer products
and G Suite for business.
Like, what's the
differences there?
JOANNA SMITH: Well, so at the
core, they're not different.
Like Gmail, at Google,
Gmail for somebody
who buys G Suite, and Gmail
for any user out there,
they're the same Gmail.
And all the features of
Gmail are there all along.
But there are some things
that are less available.
We were talking about
this earlier today anyway.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
I mean, we both use
Google Gmail at work,
and then we use
personal Gmail accounts.
And yeah, for the most part, I
don't notice a huge difference,
but I'm also not a domain admin.
And I think some of the
things Joanna mentioned
are-- one of the biggest
differences when you're running
a company, you
need those features
to be able to manage
email retention,
or manage drive files
across the company
that you don't need
to as a consumer.
There's also some other products
that are for our enterprise
customers that
we're really trying
to put out there first
with the enterprise, and--
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
Like App Maker is are
a really good example.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
It's not available to a
consumer user of Gmail,
but it is available to many
of our enterprise customers.
MARK MANDEL: What's App Maker?
JOANNA SMITH: Think if you
had like a UI visual way
to write an Apps
Script where you could
drag components
and connect them,
and the code would be generated
behind the scenes for you.
And that's what App Maker is.
So it's a really great
tool for a company that
doesn't want to spend
money hiring custom
engineers to build
solutions for them
and doesn't have a strong
engineering department,
but has people who
are smart, and clever,
and can figure it out.
So that's like a
low code alternative
to building these kinds
of solutions for yourself.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: It's also a
great way for people like me,
maybe, that would have a
sheet and a form as an app,
and my sheet is my database
to kind of scale beyond that.
So App Maker, you
can have web forms,
and you have a database
on the back end,
but it's a Cloud SQL database.
So it's kind of a different--
you know, a V2 maybe
of some sort of app I start to
build just using Google Forms
and Google Sheets.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
So we've talked a little
bit about the APIs,
we've talked about
the Apps Scripts.
Can you use some of these
extensibility features
to integrate between
G Suite and GCP?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So I say yes, and
I also say please, please do.
Because the way I see,
G Suite is actually
how people get their job done.
And if you can make
anyone's job easier,
then the whole company
becomes a lot more productive.
And that's like my shtick,
and that's what I'm out there
and I'm tweeting
and I'm working on.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
you're sticking to it.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
But the other thing
is like, let's say
several teams
across your company
all need to work with the data
inside of one of your databases
through GCP.
You don't want to
train them on how
to interact with your
database, especially
if they don't have
a lot of experience.
It's too many teams, that's
too much access, right?
So you can imagine
using like a sheet
as a front end, where
data can be pulled down
based upon certain
parameters, or what
each team needs, and then it can
be re-uploaded from the sheet
as well.
But the sheet, the collaborative
and the protective features
that are built in
by default becomes
the interface for a
lot of other teams
to work with data
you're responsible for.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Yeah, and I think--
I was really excited
at Next this year.
One of my teammates, Gabe, kind
of sent out an email saying,
hey, I have this
crazy idea, I want
to build an end to end IoT app
where we build a device onstage
and we go through
all of the process
to actually have
a UI, a front end
to show people what's
happening with those devices.
And he wanted to have both an
Angular front end and a Sheets
front end.
And I was-- you know,
because I love Sheets--
I was intrigued.
I said, oh, Sheets?
I'm like, the one person on this
team thread that loves Sheets.
So I started talking
to him about it
and we ended up
working together,
and I was part of that talk.
But what they did was build a
device using a Raspberry Pi,
so it was taking in heart rate
and temperature information.
And then they had this
fancy Angular front end
that was able to show all the
different devices in real time
what was happening.
But we also built
the Sheets front end,
and it was a place that
anybody on the team
could have pulled time slice
data from our database,
from our Firetore database, pull
it in, be able to analyze it
how you're used to a Sheets,
collaborate with others
on that data as well.
But then it had a
second function, which
was to configure the devices.
So Gabe had said
like, oh you know,
you can configure the
devices in IoT Core.
But I'm imagining
if you were going
to give a bunch of devices
out to people at a company,
you might have some
staff do that that
weren't working in IoT Core.
So this was a way that
those staff could actually
configure the devices
using Cloud Function.
So a cell in the
sheet could be updated
that could trigger a Cloud
Function to be called,
and then that would update IoT
Core with new configuration.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's awesome.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
And it was actually
really easy to do.
I think I agreed to do it before
I knew how hard it might be.
And then--
MARK MANDEL: It [INAUDIBLE].
ALICIA WILLIAMS: --I
got really lucky--
yes.
I got really lucky
because there's actually
already a library that I
found that connects Firestore
to Apps Script.
So this library--
using a service
account I could
authenticate to Firestore,
I could edit my Firestore
database all with Apps Script.
And so in the end, I had a
few features in my front end
so I could have-- the user could
put in a certain time slice
and it would pull that
device measurement data back
and show a graph in my sheet.
I also had a way to update the
device metadata in Firestore,
so say like, the
name for the device.
And then also, the
device configuration.
So the configuration is
actually stored on the device
not just in Firestore,
and this needs
to be done through IoT Core.
And so this is the part
where I could call a Cloud
Function just by-- you
know, I can have a trigger
on my spreadsheet
so anytime someone
edits the cell I can check
if that cell is edited,
and then I can call
this HTTP and trigger.
So it was actually a
pretty cool front end.
And it exposed a lot of people
in the room who had come just
to hear about IoT, they got to
hear a little bit about Sheets
too and a few people
commented on it.
So I was excited to see that
people saw the value in putting
Sheets as being a layer
in between technical teams
and other teams at the company.
MARK MANDEL: I was
actually going to ask that.
It sounds like this could
be a really, really probably
handy or possibly quick way of
getting technical teams to talk
to the business
users and vise versa,
and get that
communication going.
Is that something you're
actively looking to do?
JOANNA SMITH: Not precisely.
Like, I'm not here
to restructure
how Google gets its job done.
But one thing that's
really important to me
is making it
easier, like I said,
this whole idea of
increasing productivity
with clever and
useful solutions.
And so if I can explain
something to someone,
or if I can go to
your company, we
can give our presentation
for the whole day
and walk you through it and show
you how simple tools like this
make it easier for
knowledge to be exchanged.
That's something that I
think is a huge value, just
because being able
to communicate
with other teams who have
a slightly different lingo
is usually a
barrier, like trying
to see what you each need
or what you each call it.
But then if you
have an interface
like this where it's like, OK,
the engineering side set it up
and then the sales side
can ask for what they need,
you actually learn a lot more
about how each person works,
which can help
you make decisions
for future growth, or future
databases, or new projects,
or where to scale.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
And the immediate gratification
aspect, teams like IT teams,
or database admin
teams that are used
to having to take in
requests and constantly pull
data for a sales team or
business analysis team,
you can build this
tool, they can still
pull the data from a tool
that they are used to.
So they can ask Sheets
for a time slice of data
from a Firestore database.
So it's a way to maybe reduce
some of your own workload
for repeated requests.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's cool.
MARK MANDEL: I
can't remember who
was talking about it, with like
a BigQuery connector as well--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --so if you want
to be able to get big data out
as well.
JOANNA SMITH: So the BigQuery
data connector to Sheets,
several really
cool things I want
to make sure I say about this.
One, Google recognizes that
these kinds of connections
are popular, and
also, not everyone
has time to build their own.
So there's an effort
and a focus internally
to make sure we provide
some services that
would be really,
really advantageous
for large number of customers.
That being said, the
BigQuery data connector
is an example of one
that is-- like one
of the differences between
consumer and enterprise things,
because it would be part
of your G Suite package.
But basically
consider it as like,
we did the work already
for that exact exchange.
So everything can be done
completely from the UI,
meaning nobody has to
be trained up on it,
nobody has to tweak
it, no one in IT
is stuck being
the one person who
knows how to maintain the tool.
From Sheets you can
do a couple of clicks,
and you can be pulling data
out of your BigQuery database
even though you don't
really know how to explain
to anybody what a database is.
And that's the kind
of ease and simplicity
that we're going for.
Because without that,
you spin up your own
and you have to either
understand the BigQuery API
or you have to understand
advanced services in Apps
Script, and then
that's just a lot.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: And I think--
I had used this
before because we have
our data at Google in BigQuery.
And as a program
manager, I was constantly
trying to get Google Analytics
data, or that sort of thing,
to try to figure out
effectiveness of our programs.
And so I would use the
button in BigQuery,
that's Export to Google Sheets.
So you can-- in the BigQuery
UI, you can run a query,
you see your results,
and you can export that
to Google Sheets, which I
did all the time because I
love analyzing data in a sheet.
But now this basically takes
a step out of the process.
I no longer have to familiarize
myself with BigQuery UI.
I don't have to
export it to a sheet,
I can actually just from my
sheet connect to BigQuery,
pull my results,
my query results
are in a tab that has a Refresh
button so anytime I want
to refresh that data
I can refresh it,
and then I can connect
it to other data
in that same spreadsheet or
across other spreadsheets.
And so it really makes
it possible to access
BigQuery as somebody
that's a Sheets user.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Are there other Cloud
integrations out there
that you enjoy seeing, or you've
seen that you're excited about?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Not
necessarily an integration,
but an opportunity that I
saw this year that I actually
talked about, I blogged about,
was using our Machine Learning
APIs from a Google Sheet.
So with Apps Script, I
can call any REST API.
And so seeing that I had
certain types of data
in my sheet that were hard to
analyze just using formula,
I was able to use
our Natural Language
API from a sheet using
Apps Script to analyze
text data in that sheet.
So a common use case is people
use Google Forms to collect
feedback.
You end up with
free form feedback
perhaps in a Google Sheet,
which is backing that form.
And then normally you
would just manually read
all of those reviews,
get a sense of the data.
You might get super fancy
and make a word cloud,
but that's about it.
So that's not super useful.
This way I was able
to take that feedback,
send it over to our
Natural Language API,
have it extract out
what people were saying,
what they were talking about
and with what type of sentiment,
so using our entity sentiment
method of the Natural Language
API, copy that data back
into my spreadsheet,
and then I could visualize the
data using-- in Google Charts
or even out in Data Studio.
So it's not necessarily
an integration,
but it's a way to--
JOANNA SMITH: Wait, how is that
not an integration, Alicia?
Like, you integrated
with the two
to build this really cool demo.
And I also like how you're
like, I'm not excited about it.
That's one of my
favorite demos this year.
I talk about that
demo all the time.
I'm excited about her demo.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
I plan to continue
talking about that demo
for as long as I can.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: It sounds
like a great demo.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, it does.
JOANNA SMITH: She's all
like, yeah I know, I just
did this thing with the
MLAPIs, [INAUDIBLE] Sheets,
and it kind of counts.
It's like, no, this is
one of the coolest things
I can think about.
And how many people want that
kind of analysis that goes
beyond a chart, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I do some internal Google
events with a lot of people,
and we get a lot of
free form text response.
And being able to
actually dig through that
in an automatic
way is fantastic.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Well, the code
is available on GitHub, Mark.
Get started.
MARK MANDEL: I wish I
could just check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: You'll
have to include that link.
What about other people
that you've seen,
the work that they've done?
JOANNA SMITH: It's
not exactly Cloud,
but you could see how
it could have been.
One of the things that
amuses me to no end is--
MELANIE WARRICK: I love how
you both are couching it.
Well, it's not exactly,
but it's close.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Well if
we're goign to talk Cloud
officially, G Suite and GCP--
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
--are both part of--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MELANIE WARRICK: I was
about to say, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah, it's fine.
JOANNA SMITH: --GCP.
My bad.
One of my favorite
co-workers, he will just
write a script for anything.
Like if something
bothers him twice,
he's scripting up a
solution to it that weekend.
And so he has this
whole automated Apps
Script that he has
that anytime he
gets an email from
his child's daycare,
because they email pictures,
but the pictures are only
saved for 24 hours or whatever.
So anytime he gets an email
from his child daycare,
it triggers this script,
it takes the photo,
it copies it and saves it
locally into his drive,
and then he has
this album that's
just all of the photos
of his kids in daycare
from daily update
emails that were just
meant to be like, hey
guess what, they didn't
choke on a Cheeto or whatever.
I don't know what kids do.
Then you could see
a natural extension
of that is, now you have
years of school email updates.
Like how could you use some
of our like visual photo
recognition or image
recognition kind of APIs
to make this
something more useful,
or to collate it, or to grab the
best ones for like the holiday
Christmas card.
But this is just
like one guy who's
like, why do these emails keep
deleting, and he just fixes it.
And it didn't take
him long at all.
And that's the kind of thing
I love about Apps Script,
is just whatever
idea you have, I
bet you could probably get
it going in like a hacky kind
of way in about three hours.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: And I think
another example that really
brings into the new exciting
stuff about GCP and Cloud
that I haven't built,
but one of my co-workers
sent me an example of
it, was with the Gmail
API you can access all of
your different Gmail messages,
what you've labeled them.
So this was about kind of
training your own machine
learning model--
MARK MANDEL: Oh my
gosh, I want that.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: --to
pre-label all of your emails.
So you can use your
past email labels.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: You
can train that up.
And so then anytime
you get a new email,
it can pre-label it for you.
So I haven't built it,
but it seems very--
JOANNA SMITH: OK, I think we
have your next hackathon idea.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: --possible,
especially with the Gmail API.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I was going to say, why
haven't you built this yet?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Maybe even
AutoML, I feel like might be--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All the busswords.
JOANNA SMITH: It's funny
because this is a great example.
Like, a pro-tip
would be, use filters
to apply labels based upon
the kind of thing coming in.
But filters can take so long
to set up if you haven't really
been using them.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: So then
it's like, hey Gmail,
make my filters for me.
I'm going to write that down.
Alicia, you're doing that
at our next hackathon.
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
JOANNA SMITH: And
by you I mean we,
because you know
I'm going to help.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: This is why
I don't come to meetings.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
More action items.
MELANIE WARRICK:
The truth comes out.
MARK MANDEL: The truth
comes out, exactly.
Well thank you so much to
both of you for coming.
Before we wrap up, is
there anything else
you want to mention or plug?
Are you going to be at any
events or anything like that
that you want to make sure
that our listeners hear
from you about?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I'm planning
on going to a few Dove Fest
events.
So I'm hoping-- I think a lot
of the Google Developer Group
community talked a lot about
all of our different Google
products, but I want to make
sure G Suite is represented
well.
So I'll be speaking
at a few of those.
JOANNA SMITH: Well,
I'm very proud of you.
I intend to plant my feet
in Texas and not leave it.
So don't look for
me at conferences.
But I do manage--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I'll do twice.
I'll do twice as many.
JOANNA SMITH: --a lot
of our online content.
And there is one
other point I wanted
to make sure I kind of
touched on as we talk
about all these integrations.
I was helping edit a blog post
for the GCP Friday series,
and I had noticed and this
really, really awesome demo
that we had been
putting together
that if you're working
on an Apps Script,
if you're working on something
that's going to make something
easier for your employees,
or for the people around you,
or that you're going to try
to sell, you need to make sure
it's actually easier.
Because if it's hard
to get it going,
no one's going to use it.
And so this whole demo was
this elaborate awesome thing,
and we were really proud of it.
And it's a three part
blog series that--
I think the third part
comes out this week.
But it ended with--
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
JOANNA SMITH: --in order
to run the whole thing,
you copy a URL into the bar
and you hit the URL end point
to trigger the function.
And I was like,
this is not simpler,
this is like one more thing
to remember even though does
all this work for you.
And so I wrapped that for Martin
inside of a Custom Menu option.
So now in the
sheet for the demo,
the fake people
who totally exist
or whatever, they can click
the Custom Menu option,
and then to hit the endpoint as
easily as they can File, Print.
And so when you're
designing things--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, is this the
series with Martin Omander?
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah,
this is with Martin.
Yeah, I was working
with him on this.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we've been
mentioning it all-- sorry,
please continue.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah so, if
you are designing something
to make someone's day
easier, think about how
it will actually be used.
Try to think of it from the,
no experience, no context
perspective.
Because if somebody
knows, from the sheet
I can copy that URL saved in
that one cell and go to it,
versus I can do the
equivalent of a File, Print,
that's a much more
successful integration.
And so, just always go
that one step further,
like, how do I make this
as simple as possible
to get it going?
And pro-tip, it's usually
make a Custom Menu option.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
I always offer for
my teammates, I'm
like, if you need UX I
can be your sample user.
JOANNA SMITH: That sounds like
an offer for the whole world
here.
So just tweet her.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Oh, yes.
If you can find me, I
have a very common name.
MARK MANDEL: We have a link
to your Twitter account--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Uh oh.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, I know.
MARK MANDEL: --on the website.
JOANNA SMITH: Good, do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So everyone
will be tweeting at you, no.
Well, great.
Thank you, again, for both of
you coming onto the podcast.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
Thanks for including me.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again
to Alicia and Joanna.
I really like this episode,
I think it's a really good--
I want to say the word synergy
because it's bringing together
business users and
developers, and it feels
like that's actually a fit.
MELANIE WARRICK: It does
feel lie it's a fit.
No, it's good to talk
about, especially G Suite.
It's something we use
and it's so accessible,
and we don't think about how
much effort that really goes
into building up these
products and making them
seem less in a lot of ways.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And now I want to write a
whole bunch of Apps Script
to automate a bunch of things.
MELANIE WARRICK: You should
wrote a lot of Apps Script.
[TYPING]
Good job.
[LAUGHTER]
All right Mark, the
question of the week.
What if I want to write a
code sample with a link that
opens the Cloud Console and
automatically clones a Git
repository into Cloud Shell?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I'm actually really
excited about this,
I think it's really cool.
I think the classic example
is maybe writing a code lab,
or you have an open source
project that you want someone
to just get started
with quickly and you
wanted it to be able to
open up an environment that
has the G Cloud Tools and
all the other things that
come available with
Cloud Shell, and you just
want it to be quick and easy.
There's actually a link format
that is described in the link
that we'll put in here
called Opening Cloud Shell is
the feature, wherein you can
set your [INAUDIBLE] parameters
for like the git
repo, what git branch,
working directory, whether
you want it to be opened
in Web Editor as well.
You can also send instructions
to this [INAUDIBLE]
print values, actual
tutorial markdown file.
Basically, if you want to
build a really quick start,
like hey, get this thing
going, you can basically
just write this link and
it's kind of awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: This is a
link-- it's basically
the link to Cloud
Console with Cloud Shell
Editor with URL parameters
and boom, you're good to go.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Mark, my understanding
is you'll be at
Cube-Con in December.
Is that right?
MARK MANDEL: That
is indeed correct.
I'll be Cube-Con
talking about Argones.
Hopefully I said that
vaguely correctly.
So I'm pretty excited about
that, first time going.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then
I'll be at [INAUDIBLE]
at the end of November.
So that's where you'll find
us next other than in San
Francisco or Australia.
MARK MANDEL: Australia, I'll
be going home for a bit.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Going for a break.
All right, Mark.
I think that gives us a nice
regular wrap for the week.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Well Melanie, thank
you for joining me
for yet another week
in this podcast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]